I don't know if you guys noticed but my
hair has gotten a little crazy recently
this is the biggest my Jew fries ever
been I mean really it's about to have
its own Bar Mitzvah but seriously it's
really annoying every time my hair gets
long I don't know what to do with it I
try and like wet it I try and brush it
and no matter what it still looks like
this I've tried everything and I thought
you know what maybe I'm overthinking it
maybe my hair is not that bad so I'm
gonna go ask my friends what they really
think about my hair you got air up there
and sure enough it's on your head it's
kind of smushed right here is that
intentional no that's alright man it's
you I want it I kind of like it you
should keep it I like the way that it
shakes me to speak like that and I think
that just gives me something to distract
me from looking at your face so it seems
like my hair has a lot of mixed reviews
like the movie la-la-land
so here's what I'm thinking a lot of
people with curly hair get their hair
straightened and it looks great so I'm
gonna straighten my hair it's gonna be
amazing I'm gonna look like a sexy Game
of Thrones character like an intense
beautiful Viking with luscious hair
let's go straighten my hair I need your
help
all right I'm straightening my hair what
do I do you're not asking me this do I
look like a freakin straight in my hair
man get out of here Sarah Jesus I'm
trying to straighten my hair do you
think that's a good idea I don't think
it's gonna look good Nonna's cut your
hair where do I get a straightener it's
right across the street so they've like
good strangers get like some heat
protectant spray so hair straightening
is dangerous I think it will be
dangerous for you but for the average
person it's not dangerous
I went outside swiped my curls and
walked in there's a lot of stuff in
there I was very disoriented it was
scary I mean just so many things I
didn't know where the straighteners were
but at least they had some good music I
finally found the hot straighteners and
they were $249 I just
dollars so I better look and amazing at
the end of this video but my curls
alright so I got the stuff so the first
thing I got to do is spray this spray
stuff it's supposed to like protect your
hair I don't want to ruin my hair I
don't want it to catch on fire whoa
wow that is refreshing wow how much do I
put in I don't know I guess I'm just
gonna drench my hair in it how much do I
put in your hair my boss just said you
don't even need this stuff but I want to
protect my hair whatever I put in a
little bit smells great let's see ooh
fancy fancy this was so expensive it
better work bobbing Wow
dude this looks like the future right
here is gorgeous though look at this
design smells clean nice and white
ceramic you want to straighten your hair
but you also want to play music there's
a little on button right in here
[Music]
now I am I sneaked up with some serious
help I'm trying to straighten my hair
and I came to turn on the hair
straightener I don't understand how you
got a job alright so thanks to how the
thing is now on and it is time for me to
straighten my hair my hair is so hot I
spent 30 minutes trying to straighten my
hair but my curls are feisty so I have
to bring in some help my friend Ashley
straightens her hair every morning so I
thought she'd be good for the job after
about 45 minutes my hair finally started
to get straight it was time for me to
see my new hair really I had so much
hope that I would be sexy I look like
I'm wearing a wig alright let's go see
what people think it was your eyes and
then I want 100% honest feedback okay it
looks like you're about to get shoved
into the water but like a nice Locker
like Walker into Narnia oh you look like
a character from Riverdale well what's
it like a line from Riverdale she died I
can see he really does look like that
really I said he's straighten this here
put the part straight down the middle
please do a side-by-side comparison as
the day went on my hair got pretty crazy
I think I joined a band I mean I think
she's give back the way it was before
like it looks fine I don't know why
you're doing all this stuff Kyle was
right so I jumped in the shower and got
my curls back feels so good to have my
curls back this experience taught me to
just love whatever makes me different my
curly hair it stands out but it's me I'm
the crazy kid with crazy hair you should
always embrace things that make you
unique and if you want to try something
new don't be scared because nothing
Bad's gonna
maybe your friends will laugh at you but
that's just because they're being honest
they'll never judge you though I'm glad
I tried straight hair but I like my
curls and I'm gonna keep him I should
probably get a haircut though
[Music]